okay so little well pain 32 was not a
technique mainly techniques people use
pain rolling control person center
co-creation Nikki oh now do you remember
your first Nikki oh well then great you
all something on this technique you
share with your friends is what they
were grateful to find out how good it
was so after a while if you practice in
a way this kind of prostatic postures
feeling the power of you you get you can
absorb a lot of a lot of pain it's
always your things that's call it
naturally and you find your wrists get
stronger and you don't resist in the
jail but the force of it goes into
sensitive absorb it there's always gonna
be somebody who you can have trouble
with they just ignore the pain so you
know somebody's wants to put Nikki on if
you're on the mat you're going to do it
what are they 10 20 30 times you know
probably going to go down just to stop
me you know damaging your it may be the
guy in training with is a higher grade
Hughie's knows and really colleagues
could be all good trechie
you just go down anyway yeah you don't
don't be because I could stand in there
looking like you sir being a pain just
be awkward so let's like this look at
how to get nikkyo with with body control
so I think you know here there are
people just come straight on the risk
and go bang okay really work with me now
that's fine if it can work but it's not
used to taking video but you get to feel
what it's going to come all off and if
you've been doing it awhile you be
taking some quite severe education oh
well it's a big thing that you do it
fast all the timing and the guy fits
that
you know it's gonna hurt and you don't
actually build up any resistance all you
do is slowly build it up and the
resistance gets built up so when you get
something you just slam the audience
actually bounce of you okay so I can
take it you know just like me being up
in it I'm not resisting analyzing
through it maybe it's got pretty good
video I started her now okay now if that
was in the stream yeah I just gonna
punch in here because all the mouth yeah
oh goody I'm going to go down for that
who does that
it's quicker go you know I've got a
chance beginning now and do something so
unique come a backup plan and the
backdrop is to knock your sense around
the same time it's much more difficult
to resist a few centuries basically
destroyed why destroy the reason not so
bad
so if I want a 0 here which is going
straight into the feed what appreciate
its down you can take it a fairly
realistic day so I think two things
first thing I'm going to knock it out so
if I take the lock off I'm just working
down here I can pretty shifty but if I
push it into in sector bring that knock
your sector out so I'm actually using
force before using my fault into it send
it not backwards okay on bravely
breaking caution taking there's no pain
here you just can't stand up okay so
second thing I'm going to we put a lot
you need two things you need for really
powerful of unique compression and then
the Twix
so when I put this on I'm going to
compress this here now even we do it
people are users that they hit the floor
but not make the difference because of
the directly even downwards
inwards because you can do as you bring
techniques
looks like a striking cook from the
shoulder rather to Rizzo and so pray and
I do not ever bring this all under the
not this out
timing goes down okay so there's no
there's only two tour bus okay I don't
happen I know you you're watching this
you thinking years right-wing became
down he's laughing
you know he's not this gold fairly
severe you know indeed sir he doesn't go
down if he doesn't have to so that's
compression there to start with
and then it's up to come on okay that's
not the center L the other movement a
lot of people doing correctly I think is
coming each week
twit here okay least a bit of slider
that's fine but what so if I pins up yet
I'm going to just good really good
that's a full if I relax I can relax
release thin films yeah if I can't do
that I can probably keep you out of it
again and again it's because the
direction is losing Life Center I've put
it on here it's these forces is to get
to the rig he could twist around that or
puncture so I need to lock him but
controlling things that I do that by
bringing this here see us not be
centered on her should not be you think
so I'm not to central now when he tries
to come in on gets it now shows you a
little bit more through the it's going
to go down okay so I chose only one
smooth move so from here I've got a
queen a true sense of the taking
a healthy healthy it's directions I can
do the same throw without the risk of
f23 body movement here so when I'm
taking the key so differently so get
moving with how place by packing like
half pipe vacuum over here I believe
pinned at this point if we get a weave
it is troubling for yet our ticket back
room slow because difficulty to move
okay so these pin you down then so like
a lot okay by special request young
carry this simple moves easy okay so you
know basically fresh point on the
refugee so if new spiders paper start up
UK previous finger back I use this is
this hot enough walk through by the
pressure this is another one where it
hurts
but you know you can even of your things
if you let local his hand it's just so
freeze or muscles up around the dress
and it septic they need to follow this
over Ben directs folded over that plaque
a little muscle up here it's much more
painful when it's like that now if
you're relying on painting their
feelings don't feel it at all okay let's
build it that's good basically going
down using only pain okay what happens
when you either miss please the younger
point or you get some beautiful really
all right we train the pages
you couldn't feel it I wasn't feeling it
because I like to think I'm a good young
girl nice new filthy so whatever you can
do this boys like that working now
you've got to learn how to do it without
pain so if I checked off this point so
I'm not going to hurt on several
measures technique I'll do that one
going to be Center bringing down into
the into the pit
okay so now you care for a say it's just
a movement if you say okay so I'm doing
on taking their they're bringing forward
okay down into the fence do two
directions for you got stiff shoulders
as they get survivor you too during
these two directions the compression
goes down and if one person it if on
didn't your queue up for the UNT on
cable okay
[Applause]
same rule applies thank you okay any any
lock okay
if you hung on control person cleanser
potentially you're going to get out so I
think it's a good plan to we control
effector much you care okay
[Music]
you